the Indian leader is viewed as a
warmonger in Pakistan and they see the
stripping of Kashmir special status as a
prelude to ethnic cleansing the two
nuclear-armed neighbors both believe
Kashmir belongs to them and no one here
really thought the Indian leader was
ready to compromise if anything he's
hardened his stance his address to the
nation was wall to wall coverage in
India as he insisted he'd liberated
Kashmir from terrorism and outlined a
mouth-watering future of opportunities
the military camp down in Kashmir he
insisted his temporary and he promised
elections with the Kashmiri people
choosing their own leaders as people's
scramble to get out of the region
because of fears of violence the Indian
Prime Minister insisted there were no
benefits to article 370 the Kashmir ease
had just been deprived and left behind
for years he insisted whereabouts due to
article 370 people of Kashmir have only
had terrorism no equipment or
opportunities to help them but any
opportunities must seem a long way off
right now to the people of Kashmir with
a lockdown still in force and the
internet and phone lines cut still the
Indian Prime Minister promised a new
beginning it is the beginning of a new
era
now all the citizens of the country are
the same and they who have the same
rights
I congratulate Jammu and Kashmir Ladakh
and the whole nation very very very big
congratulations Pakistan and many
Kashmir EES see the moves as a
declaration of war
Alex Crawford Sky News thank you for
joining us the Kashmiri president of the
Pakistan side gave Sky News his first
interview with a foreign channel since
the crisis blew up and urged world
leaders to help stop the escalation the
bombs are used here by the tactical
strategic there would be a nuclear
Armageddon there would be a nuclear
winter in fact all around the world and
that won't affect only
South Asia it would affect the entire
globe the Indian leaders promise of a
new era sits awkwardly with the
draconian measures being imposed on
Kashmir and he's well aware how
incendiary his actions are Alex Crawford
Sky News Pakistan